[Music]
it's done
what is attacking hey youtubers is
charlie
happy who like week hopefully you've all
had a chance to see the Doctor Who
Christmas special now since there are so
many references going all the way back
to William Hartnell's era I thought it'd
be fun to try and find everything just
like I did during the 50th anniversary
episode I'll also be doing a Peter
Capaldi series eight predictions video
as well as a much more Sherlock videos
before the series three premiere on
January 1st be sure to subscribe to get
everything
heads up - I'm giving another $20 gift
certificate away to a random subscriber
in the comments so let's get started
this one's gonna be a whopper number one
quick and dirty at 60 minutes the
episode is the shortest episode ever
broadcast on bbc1 featuring a
regeneration technically the night of
the doctor mini episode only aired on
the red service and the web
in contrast David Tennant's final
regeneration in the end of time was 2
hours and 15 minutes long to the
narrator Tasha LEM narrates the
beginning of the episode this is the
second episode to feature a narrator at
the beginning the other time was
Rassilon
during the end of time 3 all who came
all of the spaceships you see in the
white shot above trenzalore include the
Daleks the Cybermen the Judoon
the Sontarans the Silurians the tera
leptons the slow theme family and the
Church of the papal mainframe although
technically they're an organization not
a species the configuration of their
ships is a visual callback to the enemy
Alliance during Pandorica 4 not pictured
the weeping angels the monoid and the
racnoss the weeping angels were also on
trans lore but they often travel on
other people's spaceships it's not fully
explained how they landed on the planet
as Tasha LEM said that they created a
forcefield to prevent anyone from orbit
from entering the atmosphere the mono
isn't seen on screen but is depicted as
a puppet the racnoss was also only seen
on screen in one of the children's
drawings on the wall of the clock tower
it's implied that they arrived and were
defeated sometime during the long siege
of trenzalore in the war 5 the Inverness
Cape Matt Smith is wearing an invert
escaped similar to the one worn by the
a third doctor originally Jon Pertwee
chose it as a joke and wore to a
production meeting but it's stuck the
third doctor stole the Inverness Cape
during his debut episode spearhead from
space 6 handles the reprogrammed
Cybermen hid the doctor is calling
handles is a visual reference to k9 from
the fourth doctor's run and the Sarah
Jane Adventures
he even utters canines signature phrase
affirmative 7 the phone this is the
third time matt smith has used the
physical phone outside the TARDIS
despite the 9th doctor claiming that
it's not a real phone during empty child
it's revealed that the doctor never uses
it because it's typically patched
through the TARDIS console 8 inventing a
boyfriend the doctor tells Clara that he
had an Android boyfriend once he is
referring to chameleon who was a
companion of the fifth doctor he was
last seen in a picture on the unit wall
inside the black archives during the
50th anniversary special 9 upgrades the
Cybermen in the episode are the
alternate universe
cybus versions later confirmed in
another drawing on the wall of the clock
tower which features the phrase delete
10 Clara's mother the actors playing her
start previously in the Sontaran
stratagem and during the centre Jane
Adventures 11 Clara's grandmother the
actors playing Clara's grandmother
previously starred in vengeance on
Varro's during the six doctors run 12
the apartment complex the apartment
complex Clara's family lives in is
extremely similar to the one used in the
ninth doctor's first episode Rose
interestingly enough the doctor was
carrying around a hand for a large
portion of that episode just like Matt
Smith carries around handles 13 the
doctor is naked Matt Smith also appeared
stark naked in front of Amy Pond during
the eleventh hour while he chose his new
outfit 14 holographic clothes the doctor
and Clara go to the papal mainframe
naked and are still naked when they land
on the planet in a snowstorm coldest
game of Twister ever 15 the turkey they
cooked the turkey by exposing it to the
time vortex over the course of the
episode baking the turkey is also a
metaphor for the arrival of Peter
Capaldi he's baking inside Matt Smith
for most of the episode 16 the papal
mainframe the mainframe is just the
spaceship headquarters of the church run
by Tasha LEM you can think of it as a
highly
version of the Church of England 17
Tasha LEM the actors playing her
Orla Brady mentioned during an interview
that her character and the doctor had a
romantic relationship at one point and
that Tasha was a bit cruel but the
doctor enjoyed it so much
he always forgave her there's also
theories that she's actually a version
of River Song the strongest piece of
evidence is that she is able to decode
the message from Gallifrey before the
doctor and he was only able to decode it
after using the seal of the High Council
there's also the fact that the Daleks
said that they killed her several times
and unless they revived her that would
only be possible if she could regenerate
18 the silence it's revealed that the
silence are actually a genetically
engineered order of priests their
memory-wiping abilities are merely to
prevent you from feeling guilty after
confessing your sins to them
the silence trying to kill the doctor
during series 6 were a rogue sect called
the covariance named for Madame Kovarian
they were the ones that blew up the
TARDIS creating a bootstrap paradox
which the doctor calls the Destiny trap
the silence went back in time to prevent
the doctor from answering the question
by blowing up the TARDIS but in doing so
created the very cracks in the universe
that allowed the Time Lords to
eventually ask the question you can't
change history if you're already part of
it 19 the wig the doctor got bored and
shaved his head in real life Matt Smith
filmed a movie before they filmed the
special during that time he shaved his
head
so whenever filming started on the
Christmas special he was forced to wear
a wig Karen Gillan who appeared in the
episode for a brief cameo also had to
wear a wig because she had also shaped
her head for another movie guardians of
the galaxy in more distant Doctor Who
history Paul McGann had to wear a wig
when he played the Eighth Doctor during
the TV movie 20 your ears are like
rocket fins Clara makes fun of the
doctors ears a nice visual callback to
the ninth doctors ears during his first
episode Rose he looks into a mirror and
says could have been worse look at the
ears 21 the truth field we find out that
the Time Lords are projecting the truth
field through the crack in the clock
tower along with the message we also
learned that Clara really does fancy the
doctor however we've always known the
doctor was a thief also note that the
townspeople asked the doctor his name
but he covers his mouth to keep from
saying it this is just a joke as he
doesn't know that speaking his
is what the message is all about 22 the
doctors outfit the doctor changes into
his outfit from the 2012 Christmas
special the snowmen and wears it for the
remainder of the episode until he
regenerates changing back into a series
7 outfit and then becoming Peter Capaldi
23 the crack the doctor finds that the
message is coming from the same type of
crack scene all the way back in the 11th
hour
we also learned what the doctor saw
during the god complex
in room number 11 at the time he didn't
know that it was the Time Lords who are
the ones poking holes in the universe he
was merely afraid of the weakness in the
fabric of the universe
24 the seal of the High Council the
doctor would have actually stolen it
during the events of the five doctors
when the master was sent to rescue the
doctors from the Death Zone during that
period he said that he would return the
seal upon his earliest convenience 25
the first question the reason it's
called the first question is because
it's being projected across all of time
and space meaning that it's playing at
the birth of the universe or the rebirth
depending on the events of the Big Bang
26 Doctor Who the voice speaking the
question is the General of the Council
of Time Lords seen during the 50th
anniversary 27 what's this planet called
trenzalore was the graveside of the
doctor in the series 7 finale
during that original timeline the doctor
never uttered his name and did not
receive the new cycle of her generations
which is why we saw his corpse we can
assume that the final resting place of
the doctor might still end up being
trenzalore but only based on something
else that might happen in the future 28
the doctor who stayed for Christmas the
doctor stays on trenzalore to keep the
Alliance from destroying the planet and
everyone on it he's staying more to help
the people rather than the Time Lords
the Time Lords were never in any real
danger
29 the siege of trenzalore for the first
300 years of the siege the church and
the doctor upheld the truce by keeping
out all technology not including the
sonic thus the wooden Cyberman which is
actually played by a woman during the
standoff uses the classic third doctor
phrase reversed the polarity and 30 he
also mentions that the sonic still does
not work on wood which he previously
talked about during the 2011 Christmas
special the doctor the widow in the
wardrobe and during silence in the
library 31 the cane he starts using a
cane similar to that used by William
Hartnell's doctor
he even pokes the mono a puppet with
a monster last seen during Cardinals run
30 to the dance the doctor teaches the
children the drunk giraffe as seen
during the wedding of Amy Pond in
BIGBANG 33 clara rides outside the
TARDIS just like Captain Jack Harkness
in Utopia during series 3 and the doctor
himself during hide in series 7 34
reconnect the phone before handles runs
out of power he reminds the doctor to
fix the phone making up the phone is a
metaphor throughout the episode from the
Time Lords wanting the doctor to answer
their call and help them bring Gallifrey
back to Tasha LEM trying to call the
doctor when the Daleks invaded the papal
mainframe 35 everything ends everyone's
question about which number of dr. Smith
is and how many regions he's used is
answered he tells Clara he's the
thirteenth version of himself in the
eleventh Doctor's body all thanks to
captain grumpy and at vein number 10
doubling down 36 the boy who waited
barnable asked the doctor if he's coming
back and says he'll wait the doctor
smiles remembering little Amelia pond
during the eleventh hour 37 where are
the pink ones it's unclear whether or
not the doctor is eating jelly babies or
some other type of candy as the only
other food that number 11 would crave
would be fish fingers and custard which
he eats before finishing his
regeneration 38 human form Daleks the
Daleks claimed that they killed her
several times meaning they either
resuscitated her or she regenerated
having Time Lord like abilities 39 the
first doctor when Clara returns for the
final time the doctor appears extremely
old I've seen estimates anywhere from
600 to 900 years older than he was at
the start of the episode his hair
resembles that of the first doctor
William Hartnell 40 extract from
thoughts on a clock the poem the Clara
reads is by Eric Richie jr. a character
made up as part of the story it's
unknown whether Stephen Moffat or Mark
Gatiss wrote the poem 41 the name of the
doctor Clara tells the Time Lords the
same speech that the doctor gave her
during the series 7 finale convincing
them to help the doctor they do so by
granting the doctor a new regeneration
cycle of 1242 up in the sky so they
could have totally sent the regeneration
energy through that original crack
inside the clock tower but for dramatic
effect
the production team moved the crack to
the sky 43 never tell me the rules this
is just Moffat poking fun at the fandom
obsessing over the rule of 12 for the
past six months he's just winking at us
from behind the camera
notice the glowy hands Smith's
regeneration actually started the minute
his body took in the new cycle of 12
meaning he's using his first of that new
12 to become Capaldi start the counter
we have 11 regions left 44 it's gonna be
a whopper the doctor is regenerating for
the 13th time which is extremely unusual
as a consequence he's giving off more
energy during the process it's likely
that when Capaldi eventually regenerates
he'll give off even more energy 45
taking a bit longer in the final moments
that we see him he's just an echo of 11
and the first whisper of 12 just enough
time to have some fish fingers and
custard and think about an old friend
46 goodbye a raggedy man the doctor
remembers Amelia pond across her
lifetime as she was a child when they
first met and then later as an adult
it's not a bad wolf situation he's just
seeing her in his memory it's been six
years
so the actress playing young Amelia is
different but karen gillan returned to
film the scene as mentioned earlier she
and Smith were both very bald in the
scene and wearing wigs 47 bowties will
always be cool
Smith dropping the bowtie is the bookend
to his run on Doctor Who the bowtie
belonged to his character just like the
scarf belong to Tom Baker don't be
surprised if Peter Capaldi does not wear
any kind of neck wear 48 I've got new
kidneys Peter Capaldi's doctor upholds
the tradition that all new doctors
always fixate on their physical features
first 49 do you happen to know how to
fly this thing new doctors are typically
disoriented after regenerating the
eighth doctor didn't even know who he
was 50 the final frame Clara's reaction
shot ending is the first regeneration to
end on a character that is not the
doctor there were so many parts of the
episode that incorporated things from
classic ooh be sure to let me know in
the comments if you saw anything that I
didn't mention in my video this was
super long so you are a champ if you
made it to the end don't forget I am
giving away of $20 Amazon gift card to a
random subscriber in the comments right
now you can click here to get my
Christmas special QA and you can click
here to get my review thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you